and a warning it does contain some video
that's upsetting of a woman in pain
blood transfusion and that blood has to
be ethnically matched that's life with
sickle cell
it can be overwhelming I feel like I
couldn't breathe I felt like my chest
was closing up felt like my back was on
fire my whole body was hurting how often
do you have to have blood transfusions
every six weeks I have a transfusion and
do you ever worry that bloodstocks will
run low I do
I do worry I worry because
not a lot of black people are donating
that's a problem you see more than half
of all black people in the UK have what
ciliana needs it's the RO blood type
it's not rare but it's in high demand
every day 250 donations are needed to
treat Sickle Cell It's the fastest
growing genetic condition in the country
but only one percent of active blood
donors across the whole of the UK are
black chair of the John Lewis
partnership Dame Sharon White is one of
them sometimes you don't do that which
you don't see and so I think having more
publicity and just more
focus on on black people and that it's a
and it's a kind of regular
thing to do so hopefully of campaign or
the publicity around today will be you
know hopefully those numbers will zoom
up in the next seat is a first time
donor and founder of operation black
vote I think most people are afraid of
noodles aren't they particularly the big
ones but I know this is for a great
cause not just a not just a good course
a great one both donors want their
Community to join them in this simple
yet potentially life-saving act of
kindness after all it uses power that's
already running through our veins Sadia
Chaudhary Sky News